[Music]
no I'm not saying locals don't exist I'm
saying that when quantum mechanics
effects are taken into account than
singularities the singularity theorem is
violated
I think there's a lot of indirect
evidence for the existence of black
holes I think very soon we're going to
have direct evidence we're going to
point a bunch of telescopes at the
center of the galaxy and we're going to
look at for this event horizon this dark
circle
black holes exist but a weird okay
there's abundant Astrophysical evidence
for stellar mass and supermassive black
holes
afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to bang goes another theory of
the universe we do get to a lot of
theories at this festival I must say
what we're discussing is back holes
really early in his career Hawking and
Penrose who was here just last weekend
described black holes and claimed that
they break all of the known physical
laws so in other words in our universe
our little pockets which don't run
according to the laws of the rest of the
universe which is an extraordinary
thought since then they've been found at
the center of galaxies but now some
leading cosmologists Hawking's amongst
them are begin to say they doubt that
black hole exists so our black holes
more of a science fiction than a fact
and and if so what's really at stake
does it do violence to the theory of
relativity does it do violence to our
Theory the beginning of the universe to
help us discuss this we have our three
panelists to my right Laura masini
halton I see you again professor of
physics at the University of North
Carolina widely covered New Scientist
and BBC because you are no stranger to
controversy one of the people who has
researched the ways that we can gather
experimental evidence for other
universes for the multiverse and not
content with ruffling those feathers
she's now telling us that there may be
evidence to suggest that back holes
don't exist and to my left Michael
Ron Robinson astronomer astrophysicist
at Imperial College London former
president of the Royal Astronomical
Society he was awarded the Royal medal
first research in cosmology and has
pioneered the technologies now aboard
the Herschel Space Telescope well and
the Planck satellite is that right
involved yes wonderful and wait is it to
you also the PhD supervisor for really
ha I had to bring a duck sorry and
we have a Pedro Ferreira professor of
astrophysics University of Oxford you
wrote the book a perfect theory the
perfect theory to do with the battles
which have already been waged around
general relativity and that book was
shortlisted for the Winton war society's
science book prize and shortlisted for
physics world book of the year um I'll
ask each of our panelists to give us
their views in four minutes I'll try and
hold them to that and then we will set
to the debate and if I could start with
you Lara
so Blackhawks have have quite an
interesting history if you think of the
first Oppenheimer Snyder work that used
general relativity to show the existence
of black holes and how Oppenheimer at
this 20-year long debate with John
Wheeler who ironically ended up coining
the the word black hole and then you
think of Eddington and Chandra Sekhar
Chandra Sekhar again did pioneering work
and using general relativity show the
existence of black holes and Eddington
didn't like that a bit so the point that
he called it the stellar goof honoré and
of course after that I don't think there
is anyone that doubts the existence of
black holes especially with with the
very important work by Sir Roger Penrose
and Stephen Hawking things got a bit
tricky after the discovery of Hawking
radiation by Hawking in the early 70s
and the reason is because pretty soon
people realize that if you use quantum
mechanics and therefore obtain Hawking
radiation you end up with the huge
paradox known as the information loss
and that's no good because it in a
nutshell it forces us to rethink this
age long battle between general
relativity and quantum theories if we
accept Hawking radiation which we do
then we have to doubt the foundations
onto which the existence of black holes
is established because of the
information loss quantum mechanics has
this sacred principle that states no
information can ever be lost in that
case anything that goes down a black
hole and disappears down a singularity
produces these paradox where all the
information is in principle we could
stop the whole universe down a black
hole down the singularity of a black
hole and lose that information forever
but yet at the same time we would use
this quantum theory that has just been
violated to deduce the existence of
Hawking radiation so it and
this debate has been going on for at
least 30 years many great scientists
have tried to come up with different
ways of solving it but the paradox
persists and it seems that we either
have to transform to make an external
relativity or wave our hands in the air
and say perhaps we need that unknown
theory of quantum gravity right we're
back to that to my experience whatever
we end up with such a bland paradox such
as the information loss usually
something very basic and elementary has
been missed out on the beach when you
say information lost you mean the
information that's connected with the
matter that disappears into now is it
your opinion now that the evidence is
now against black holes existing for
whatever reason people have grown very
attached to the word black holes I think
part of it has to do with with the
culture that that spread beyond the
physics community so no I'm not saying
that all don't exist I'm saying that
when quantum mechanics effects are taken
into account than singularities the
singularity theorem is violated and
singularities may not exist what you
have instead is some sort of huge
massive object that would have the same
mass and gravitational field as a black
hole but it would not have this exotic
singularity at the centers in that case
you don't have the informational paradox
look I mean if you look at the history
that Laura's mentioned there's an ebb
and flow with regards to black holes
so actually in 1915 Einstein puts out
his theory one of his colleagues solves
his theory and comes up with a solution
and let's just be clear what we mean by
black holes we mean a bit of space-time
we're right at the center it's very
symmetric so she notes it's round
a right at the center the the geometry
is just infinite it's very very sharply
curved and then a little bit out there's
a kind of a shroud there's a surface
which is what's known as that have the
event horizon and stuff that goes into
this event horizon can't come out short
she'll comes up with this and Einstein
he says this is a solution but it's very
mathematical and and that's kind of been
the tennis throughout so you know the
last hundred years is that someone looks
again at black holes comes up with a
more physical model and someone says
well actually it's it's just mathematics
Stella buffoonery that you mentioned the
Eddington and I just think there is this
Evan flow where at some point someone
disagrees it you know someone thinks
that there's something wrong with black
holes okay so that's just going to
happen for a while well it all boils
down to you know mathematical evidence
for it is definitely there it all boils
down to observational evidence and I
just I don't you know I don't want to
rain on your parade I'm gonna let you
talk about the observational evidence
but one of the things that III think
there's a lot of indirect evidence for
the existence of black holes I think
very soon we're gonna have direct
evidence we're gonna point a bunch of
telescopes at the center of the galaxy
and we're going to look at for this
event horizon this dark circle and we're
basically the telescope's are going to
be sufficiently resolved that we're
going to be able to make a take a
photograph of it and we're gonna see
we're gonna see if this event horizon is
there or not
so my answer to you is I think
ultimately it's an experimental question
it's an observational question and we're
going to see if it's there or not now
there are various aspects to this the
fact what happens right at the center
you know what happens to this shroud and
these we're debating these bits of it
so I want to say four things summary
first black holes exist but a weird this
is K there's abundant Astrophysical
evidence for stellar mass and
supermassive black holes I'll just say a
little bit about those in my view the
problem is it's Hawking radiation does
not really exist I'll explain what I
mean
[Music]